نعم عثمان لكن دعنا نشير فقط الى هذا
الانفجار الضخم
الذي نعم هو حقيقه انفجار ضخم الان في وسط
مدينه غزه وواضح حجم هذا الانفجار في نفس
الموقع الذي كان يستهدف في الساعات
الاخيره من قبل الطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي
اذا غاره جويه جديده الان على مدينه غزه
على وسط مدينه غزه على وجه الخصوص وهي
تبدو قريبه ايضا من مقر مكتب الجزيره في
مدينه غزه هذه المنطقه ايه عثمان تستهدف
في اليومين الماضيين على نحو كبير هنالك
اشتباكات عنيفه ايضا تسمع من تلك المنطقه
بين الحين والاخر بواسطه ال رشاشات من
العيار الثقيل وهذه غاره جديده من سلسله
غارات كان الطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي قد
شنها على هذه المنطقه منذ ساعات اي ما قبل
ظهر هذا اليوم لان الهدوء كان حقيقه سيد
الموقف في الساعات الاولى من الصباح
وانقلب المشهد هنا على شكل غارات جويه
وقصف مدفعي لكن هذا اليوم هو يوم الغارات
الجويه
حقيقه الكثير منها شاهدناها في وسط
المدينه تحديدا في هذا الموقع الذي نراه
الان على الشاشه وكذلك في المناطق
الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه سواء كان ذلك الاحياء
الجنوبيه للمدينه الاحياء الجنوب الغربيه
منها كانت ايضا تعرضت هذا اليوم لغارات
جويه وقبل نحو ساعه ايضا كانت هنالك غاره
جويه عنيفه على المناطق الشماليه لمدينه
غزه هذا بالاضافه الى منطقه جحر الديك هذه
المنطقه الواقعه الى جنوب مدينه غزه التي
كانت تعرضت ايضا هذا اليوم لقصف مدفعي
ولغات جويه متتاليه لكن بعض الغارات
الجويه عثمان حقيقه كانت قريبه جدا من
السياج الامني من السياج الحدودي لقطاع
غزه وهذا يعني بان الغارات الجويه كانت
كما يبدو تستهدف في كثير من الاحيان
مجمعات سكنيه قريبه من المنطقه الحدوديه
من السياج الامني من خط الهدنه هذا هذه
الغارات تستهدف كما يبدو مربعات باكملها
في اطار رؤيه الجيش الاسرائيلي لتدمير هذه
المنازل لتدمير المصالح التجاريه لتدمير
المرافق الاقتصاديه القريبه من السياج
الامني وهنالك كثير من هذه المرافق التي
جرى تدميرها في الاسابيع الماضيه في اطار
النهج الذي يتبعه الجيش الاسرائيلي لخلق
هذه المنطقه العازله التي كنا نتحدث عنها
في الاسابيع
والايام الماضيه الاف الشقق السكنيه الاف
الشقق السكنيه عثمان تم تدميرها ومسحت من
الوجود مباني شاهقه من ثلاثه واربعه طوابق
دمرت تقريبا بالكامل بعضها بشكل ش شبه
كامل وبالتالي لم تعد صالحه للسكن لم تكن
لم تعد صالحه للعيش وبالتالي هذا التدمير
الممنهج هو هدفه منع الفلسطينيين من من
العوده الى هذه المناطق التي يريد الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان يبقي سيطرته الامنيه
والعسكريه عليها حتى بعد انتهاء الحرب في
اطار خلق هذه المنطقه العازله التي كنا
نتحدث عنها في الاسابيع الماضيه عثمان